and i'm just getting word here i'm just
getting word here i think i think that
person who trump endorsed
uh is joining us now um his name is jd
mandel jd
mandel is that is that you
yes hi jd mandel thank you for having me
jd how how are you how are you uh you
know um
uh i i you know i've had better days you
know what what does your hat what does
your hat say
it says uh donald trump knows my name
okay okay so i mean he he called me you
know we i'm gonna i'm gonna say this um
really didn't expect it but this past
weekend he called me out by name at the
ohio rally yeah i mean i think i think
it really pushed me in the polls a
little bit um
so
you know i appreciate the uh the shout
out well um maybe we'll pull up that
video here of of trump um actually
um endorsing you would uh what appears
to be endorsing you on stage
i mean love to hear my name you know
yeah jd mandel
let's well he he kind of got your name
wrong there at first jd yeah you know it
makes sense he's an older guy you know
he said you know he mixed up the d and
the p but he got there but he got right
there right so let's let's listen let's
listen to your mussolini jesus as it
appears you're a trump supporter right
you love trump he supports me so i
support him oh okay so that's how it is
you know yeah it's kind of a circle jerk
kind of thing i get it i get it sounds
like trumpism um so here here is here is
your mussolini jesus uh appearing to say
your name that's what they're waiting
for they're waiting for one race you
know we've endorsed dr oz we've endorsed
jp right j.d mandel here i am and he's
doing great they're all doing good he
said you were doing great there
jd uh mandel
oh man you know again i wasn't really
expecting it but as soon as does that
give you a boner it really seems like it
gave you a boner there
i mean you if you hear your name said by
trump on stage in front of you know a
few dozen people it is quite a trip oh
okay well it might be for someone who
thinks he's uh the republican jesus but
for someone who doesn't
anyway so let's get back to the other
people in this race were you how many
votes did you receive yesterday
um in the ohio prime minister
like counting my own
did you write yourself in is that what
you're saying uh i did i mean my name
wasn't officially on the ballot but
oh i took advantage of an opportunity
and i i you know i was a write-in you
went ahead and voted for yourself yep
yep okay well that that makes sense
because you know you had a couple other
opponents on the ballot you actually had
jd vance which is i think who trump
originally endorsed are you aware of
that and he kind of shares the same
first yeah
but you know what
i guess he just knew that a uh a prado
ohioan like myself uh yeah should be the
candidate okay well there's also another
guy on the ballot that appears to have a
similar name as yours his name is josh
mandel so j is his first initial i don't
know if p is his middle initial or not i
have no idea but his last name is mandel
so he shares the same last name a lot of
people i will say this a lot of people
are saying that josh mandel photoshopped
himself into uh photos uh while serving
you know if you look at his hands
they're a little bit darker than his
skin some people said he photoshopped
himself so so you don't like josh mandel
you're not you're not no no no no is is
he your cousin or something you know you
guys share the last name i didn't know
if like it was your cousin no i mean
look i'm not going to do the 23andme and
try to figure out our relationship but
from what i understand we are not
related
um sure hope not um
but uh no i am my own man and uh i at
least for the most of what i know we are
not related we just happen to be you
know a couple mandels in one town you
know
ah just a couple of mandels in the same
town well that's that's very interesting
uh so how do you think because it
appears that jd vance is going to win
the primary he's going to be the
republican candidate on the
ballot for the midterm election even
though he
you probably did you see the the lincoln
project ad i just played where he's a
never trumper that he's been a never
trumper for a long time yeah
uh
jd vance is a backstabbing hypocrite oh
he is okay well
so so you're saying i know he stole my
girlfriend in high school oh he did he
did this is news this is news everyone
breaking news
uh jd vance stole jd mandel's
girlfriend in high school and it seems
like you're very upset about this i am i
mean i i really thought we were going to
go the distance you know we were going
to get married we're going to have kids
we're going to get that you and you and
jd are you in this this
lovely lady oh my well my girlfriend and
i wanted her to be my wife i thought it
was really going to be that you know
we're a couple high school sweethearts
and uh you know jd uh pretended to be
this jd oh um you know
so this isn't the first time he's trying
to impersonate you i guess i mean look
we were at a party okay we were playing
seven minutes in heaven okay i was
supposed to go in there with my
girlfriend okay okay
and then the next thing i know i'm going
to get us a couple drinks i'm like
where's lindsay and they said they're in
the closet together with jd and i said
what do you mean and you're like yeah
you say i'm jd i'm jj i said i'm jd and
i was like i'm jd i was getting us
drinks and they said oh no she's in the
closet right now with jd they're playing
seven minutes in heaven
and i said whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
what
this sounds like seven minutes in hell
to me
so then they come out of the closet
bingo bango next thing i know
they're dating oh okay so he stole your
girlfriend and you could you could hear
her in the closet she was like oh jd oh
jd between kisses she was like oh jd and
i was like i'm jd i'm jd
right and then and then she comes out
again i tell you she comes out and she's
like i'm with this jd oh so you know
what shows that
what was that what was it again i said
[ __ ] jd vance oh okay okay not not
not [ __ ] you jd no why but she did she
did [ __ ] him though right she did she
didn't [ __ ] she did [ __ ] him though
right like is that what you're saying
i agreed to come on i didn't want to i
didn't want i'm just trying i'm just
trying
to talk about the event
the votes and me running right right in
you know oh you know i really thought
that i was gonna be uh right become that
kid you know i was gonna be i could have
been a contender you know like i thought
i was gonna be
i had a real shot okay because he said
your name on stage i get it so so let's
talk about jd vance as the candidate not
as the guy who stole your your
girlfriend right um and you [ __ ] your
girlfriend let's talk about the guy who
won who appears to win the primary of
the republican last night um jd vance
he's got a lot of views um that seemed
to be kind of i don't know anti-american
almost to me
and even even to his opponent tim ryan
um who is the person who won the
democratic ticket tim ryan um is the
person who's going to run as the
democrat so we have in the in the
midterm election you're going gonna have
jd vance the guy who who stole and
[ __ ] your girlfriend and then tim ryan
probably the guy who
appears more like a guy who would steal
right in fact your girlfriend um but
those two are gonna compete in this race
what do you have to say about jd vance
you know him appearing to not be as
america first as maybe the the fascist
uh maga trump humping movement like
you're a part of
right
what tell us about that what
what i'm sorry what what did you just
call me i i said you're part of the
fascist maga trump humping movement oh
yeah yeah the q and the q anon movement
yeah yeah yeah i i wasn't misspeaking
jfk jr is coming back yeah
he called america a joke okay he said uh
our country's kind of a joke i'm sorry
uh our founding fathers didn't think
that
it's like i mean get with it you know
it's like if you truly are a patriot
america is not a joke right america is
the city upon a hill okay right that
shining beacon of light right that place
in which other people come to us as
they're saving grace okay
okay so so you're saying you're saying
that
if you had a candidate that thought that
jd vance was the joke instead of
jd vance thinking the country was a joke
you might vote for them is that what
you're saying
you're saying that boy sorry say that
one more time if you had a candidate out
there in your because you live in ohio
you're a voter in ohio yeah i hope i
hope you're registered to vote if you
went and wrote in yourself i'm in ohio
yes okay and so if you're registered in
ohio wouldn't you want to vote for a
candidate that is against jd vance
saying that our country's a joke and
that he's kind of a joke and he
definitely would probably want to make
sure
uh to not make money like in china or
overseas it sounds a little hunter
biden-ish doesn't it it does you know jd
where's jd's laptop am i right well i i
want to know i i would like to is he
writing a sequel to his dumb book i did
you read this book can you read i mean i
guess i should ask you that first can
you read hillbilly wannabe that's what
it is yeah right right well he is a
hillbilly wannabe for sure but but it
sounds like you would vote for a
candidate who was on the same page as
you about jd vance the guy who stole
your girlfriend you should you should
want to vote you won't you should want
to vote for someone from ohio who wants
to work for the american people who
doesn't just up and leave for a
hollywood elites right his leftist
friends right go be a correspondent on
cnn cnn wait wait you mean do you mean
jd vance the guy that stole your
girlfriend was on on fake news as a
correspondent he was paid by fake news
yeah he was a an
analyst
analyst oh i i see i see
you're not you're not it's analyst it's
analyst it's spelled like anal well
right right
anal
ist
analysis he's an analyst okay okay okay
fair enough
okay tony i'm not over here writing
dictionaries okay
i'm really reading them you know
well that analyst he's an analyst with
the fake news network cnn apparently
yeah so you would vote for you would
vote for a guy who was opposed to this
stuff then is what you're saying oh i
would most definitely vote for a guy
that was totally against jd vance that
[ __ ]
girlfriend stealing wannabe hillbilly i
well i i don't blame you i don't blame
you that you would vote against
jd vance and make sure to keep ohio in
ohio right to make sure it's someone who
is ohio who is born in ohio raised in
ohio four ohioans who doesn't call
america a joke who doesn't call our
country a joke exactly that's who that's
who the people should be voting for you
know i found a video
of a candidate and i believe this is uh
his name is tim ryan he's running on the
ticket too i i can't figure out from
this video if he's a democrat or
republican maybe you can tell me uh if
you'd vote for this candidate here um
let's play it here see if you'd vote for
this candidate people may not always
agree with my rhetoric but i think
unfortunately our country's kind of a
joke
that's what i said advance left ohio for
san francisco to make millions and
invest in companies that profit from
globalization and free trade he became a
celebrity cnn analyst and he's a big hit
at washington cocktail parties now vance
says he feels out of place in ohio and
he wants to represent you in the senate
what a joke
i'm tim ryan and i approve this message
so you think people may not know
jd jd do you think you would vote for
tim ryan over jd vance yeah i would vote
for if i knew that tim ryan was running
and i didn't have to write myself in i
would have voted for tim ryan oh would
you this is great this is great news
because i believe the news is i don't
think it's official yet but i believe
the news is that tim ryan if you are
registered in ohio you will be able to
go vote for him in november during the
midterm election jd well i'm going to
vote for i mean you know clearly i only
got eight votes you know including mine
but wait wait you had eight people vote
for you
yeah
eight
eight people including myself i mean one
one also my my mom and then my sister so
you know but eight people voted that's
pretty good that's pretty good eight
votes on the ballot that's but if you're
telling me that this guy tim ryan i
don't know who this guy is but if you're
telling me this guy is running in
november oh [ __ ] yeah oh yeah he's
running he's running
he's a democrat he's a democrat running
in ohio he's on the democratic ticket so
so go vote go vote for yeah he's a he's
a democrat he's a democrat that's right
that's right and he's he's making sure
to be against uh jd vance being a a
traitor to ohio going to san francisco
making money off china and all the
elitist and then being an analyst as you
call it analyst on fake news cnn
yeah tony i feel like you're putting me
between a rock and a hard place right
now oh yeah you're telling me that this
guy's anti-jd which i'm anti-jd okay
right right you're you know all the
points that i brought up during the
during this interview you know tim ryan
said exactly those same things it's
almost like we're on the same wavelength
i know and you're telling me that this
guy is going up against jd vance in
november yeah well q anon is a hypocrite
listen listen jd q anon is a hell of a
drug it's a hell of a drug and you
really
you really should maybe check out um you
know you know some things on the side of
facts and that might help you through
this process jd it really might help you
through this process i don't know i'm
feeling i'm feeling very confused right
now
um
i don't know i don't know what to
believe anymore well i tell you what
we're gonna take a break and i
appreciate you joining us jd please come
back uh more during this election to
give us your insight into how you're
feeling about uh tim ryan running
against your enemy jd vance yeah um and
i got a special a special commercial for
you so don't forget to watch through the
break jd
um because there is a there is a special
trump fund out there for people who are
sad and broken like you there is and um
so everyone
out there yeah so jd thanks